really toxic people I avoid I treat film
like a military I got out to Hollywood
and we discovered incredible lack of
money you are all going to die
hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from director Joss Whedon
and my take on his top 10 rule to
success rule number two is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always as
you're listening if something really
resonates with you is a message that
really holds true to you please leave it
down in the comments below and put it in
quotes so that other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
as well enjoy
do you like actors
generally speaking I'll just be I'll be
back in a couple minutes
the weird thing as many of my best
friends are actresses right
I love actors and I did not think I you
know I I answer again in the old school
it's an adversarial relationship and and
I've worked in my share of divas but I
also have enormous respect for divas
they're usually people who do something
extraordinary and know it and show up
and do it and you have to deal with a
lot of other stuff but they usually come
in and say you're going to have to deal
with a lot of other stuff I'm a diva so
here we go
and and then you get this beautiful work
and you're like okay yeah you know
thanks for the heads up really toxic
people
I avoid I cast for sanity that's a very
important thing to me but talk to people
are different than divas divas are
complicated but they know that there is
a simplicity to what they're going to
give you that you need and want and
truly toxic people are just about trying
to tear something down whether it's
somebody else in the thing whether it's
the story there about power those people
have no business in my life as far as
I'm concerned in the industry as a
filmmaker
you have to it's sort of a bad teacher
thing you have to be sure when you're
working for somebody else that's it
they're the boss I treat film like a
military I always have film and
television when I'm working for someone
and they're telling you know if they're
Henry Fonda and Porter pachi and they're
making all the wrong decisions I listen
to them because someday I'm going to
take over and expect the same thing and
it's not that I don't want the center I
don't I don't want to make a creative
collaboration that's very exciting for
me but you have to be in charge know
what you want and know that you have the
ability to get that and requires a lot
of fierceness and a lot of belief more
belief than other people are going to
have in you when I shock the first thing
I ever shot was a pilot presentation for
Buffy and it was a nightmare
none of the crew understood what I was
trying to do or thought I could do it
and there was a point at which I just
want to fold just can I please go home
and be a writer but I was miserable just
being a writer because I wasn't creating
the thing whole that I wanted to and at
some point in the shoot I just I said to
myself this is it this is your pep talk
you're either going to go home and
regret it for the rest of your life
you're going to go in there and run this
thing
in fact your first work it was a
television job I think it's Ravana that
correct oh yeah that was my first job so
with with that did you always want to do
television I know that you come from a
television family or did you did you go
out to Hollywood to work in film or
television how did that work I would
never do television
I was that was beneath me and study film
and my bad my best friend senior year
used to taunt me so you're gonna be a
third generation television writer we
didn't wanna put it through GTV
you told me that all the time and then I
you know I got out to Hollywood and
discovered incredible lack of money and
so I sort of started poking my nose
around in the me like oh there's some
very good televisions being made and and
as soon as I started writing it which is
really the first writing I'd ever done
over my television specs that I wrote
trying to get a job and that's when I
fell in love with writing was through
television so and I had the privilege to
work on Roseanne which was you know he
was the best show on and it really it
had a level of reality that no other
show is really busting out just then
well the difficult story line like widow
and Tara's a lesbian love on TV
abdominal no we do it very gradually I'm
not sure they knew that that's what it
was
boy that seems like a very intense still
there caster
um sir my voice is so loud in my ear
that I but um you know again I've always
sort of approached things with the idea
of that whoever is giving me all that
money to put it on as my partner
and that ain't I'm not I'm not working
against them I'm trying to work with
them I'm trying to find the space
between my artistic expression their
commercial needs and my artistic
expressions commercial I want to make
things that people like I'm not trying
I'm not wearing a beret and sitting in a
garret and smoking more because it makes
me reflect um occurred but um you know I
I understand what they need and and what
they wanted I like that and I also think
with audiences you know I used to say we
could have made Buffy - lesbian
separatist but let's start the Vampire
Slayer and and you know you you always
want to sort of get people at the edge
of their comfort level there are a lot
of things that I do that you know people
like robots and that's pretty edgy I'm
like really
I don't it surprises me that it's not
morning stream let's just say
hypothetically the two roads diverged in
a wood and you took the path less
traveled
part of you is just going look at that
path over there it's much better if
everybody's traveling on it and it's
paved and there's a there's like a
Starbucks every 50 yards it's a recent
wrong this one there's nettles and
Robert Frost's body and somebody should
have moved bad I think that's it feels
weird and not only is your mind telling
you this
it is on that other path it is behaving
in as though it is on that path it is
doing the opposite of what you are doing
and for your entire life you will be
doing on some level the opposite not
only of what you are doing but of what
you think you are that is just going to
go on what you do with all your heart
you will do the opposite of and what you
need to do is to honor that to
understand it to unearth it to listen to
this this other voice all right
Elizabeth Knapp because otherwise it's
coming off in a dramatic fashion at the
wrong time I know I worked on the Terra
for a long time I had a busted out you
have which is a rare thing the ability
and the responsibility to listen to the
dissent in yourself to at least give it
the floor okay because it is the key not
only the consciousness but to real
growth to accept duality is to earn
identity and identity is something that
you are constantly earning it is not
just who you are it is a process that
you must be active in and it's not
parenting your parenting your parents or
even the thoughts of dear learning
teachers is now more than ever about
understanding yourself so you can become
yourself and I talked about this
contradict in a detention there's two
things I want to say about it
one it never goes away
and if you think that achieving
something if you think that solving
something if you think a career or a
relationship
we'll quiet that voice it will not if
you think the happiness means total
peace you will never be happy
peace comes from the acceptance of the
part of you that can never be at peace
it will always be in conflict if you
accept that everything gets a lot better
the other reason is because you are
establishing your identities and your
beliefs you need to argue yourself down
because somebody else will somebody is
going to come at you there whatever your
belief your idea your ambition
somebody's going to question it and
unless you have first you won't be able
to answer back you won't be able to hold
your ground you don't believe me try
taking a stand on just one leg you need
to see both sides
because I never studied writing I just
sort of had to learn on the job my
entire family my mother's my father
everyone around them teachers and
writers and very erudite very articulate
people that would come hard for me to
sort of find a voice but it took me just
training on the job working relentlessly
since today I started to sort of
discover what it was that I was doing
and sort of discover the structures
behind the voices that I was created how
did you settle on matcha tea I mean is
your favorite Shakespeare play or is it
just it's up there it's not my very
favorite but it is it's one that we
always talked about doing because we
knew amy and alexis should definitely be
Beatrice and Benedick and and it's all
in one place and you know it's sort of
low stress but for years I just didn't
have a take on the material and then
finally when I realized I did I said
okay it's go time and that really that
movie exists because of years and years
of working with actors that I absolutely
knew could do that as though it were
live theatre could walk on set and never
get it wrong and because we you know the
schedule was exactly the same as a TV
show
no actually was worse and it was
actually tighter than a regular Network
TV show and and you know obviously the
language slightly different and no stage
directions practically so it was like a
ton of work every day and you can only
do that when you know you have an
ensemble who is you know just strength
to strength so it's really them they're
they're my secret I mean my my secret
but me
the pressure is greater if you have
characters that already exist or in the
case of Avengers some of them you know
we've had been cast and had their own
films some of them were beloved from
comics but we were reinvented within the
film's meeting everybody's expectations
really just means meeting your own it
means that you understand these voices
and that people you're making the film
for hear them the same way that you do
people at Marvel are very clear that
when you make a film of a comic book or
when you make a film with the character
from another film you cannot do exactly
what was done before you have to
translate it to your own film and you do
it in their style in their you know sort
of the house style of Marvel which you
know which I grew up with and I feel I
understand pretty well but but you have
to make it personal and you have to
translate it to a new audience to
somebody who hasn't seen or read or any
of the other things while keeping the
essence of the thing some somebody will
always argue with the way you do it but
nobody can argue with my passion for
doing it and I think that's what people
are really looking for more than the
specifics as well in the comic is
costume head up let's hear one big issue
removable you've had a really wonderful
few years and you've had a little bird
yes I had a good run
how are you going how do you feel about
it how do you feel about where you are
right now are you or over yeah that's
how we always feel all right yeah this
is this is a bad one I mean I know you
get that after any project probably it's
over
yeah the jig is up yes they're going to
know yeah
yep it's worse this time partially
because you know of the Ultron thing
which was difficult and I I should just
say because I I feel like when I I feel
like part of like Ultron I am very proud
of there were things that did not meet
my expectations of myself and I you know
and then I sort of I was so beaten down
by the process some of that was
conflicting with Marvel which is
inevitable but a lot of it was about my
own work and then and I was also
exhausted and then we went right away
and did publicity and I sort of created
the narrative wherein I am not quite
accomplished it and people just ran with
that and so it became well it's okay it
could be better but it's not Josh's
fault and and I think that did a
disservice to the movie and to the
studio and to myself ultimately was it
was not the right way to be because I am
very proud of it the things about it
that are wrong frustrate me enormous Lee
and I had you know probably more of
those than I have on the other movies
I've made but I also got to make for the
second time an absurdly personal movie
where I got to talk about how I felt
about humanity and what it means in very
esoteric and bizarre ways for hundreds
of billions of dollars like the fact
that Marvel gave you that opportunity
twice is so bonkers and so beautiful and
the fact that I come off of it feeling
like a miserable failure is also
Bunker's but not in a cute way like it
becomes problematic and I don't know
what it's like for you I took my first
vacation ever after that movie and I
don't mean ever but my first vacation
that was more than two weeks in 25 years
except for
one four month vacation where I wrote
the Buffy musical that was lonely and so
and really set out to do nothing to
accomplish nothing I'm proud to say that
I have truly a conjugate there yeah I
really I got to a higher state of all
this life for you that's an expense of a
major departure I'm proud I'm also but
my resting state is is not it's not a
good one
you work hard I mean I work hard I love
to work I love the work that I do and
I'm very happy and grateful about it
when I'm not doing it I remember that I
hate myself and so it's not it's not
doing so much to be sorry the vacations
over now I'm writing again
and so how you bad daddy thank you yeah
okay when I was sitting where you guys
are sitting the speaker was Bill Cosby
funny man and Bill Cosby he was very
funny and he was very brief and I thank
him for that
but he gave us a message that I really
took with me that a lot of us never
forgot about changing the world he said
you're not going to change the world so
don't try that was in like he didn't buy
that back at all and then complained
about buying his daughter a car and we
left and what I remember thinking you
know I think I could do better
I think maybe I could be a little more
inspiring than that and so what I'd like
to say to all of you is that you are all
going to die
[Music]
okay so this is a good function because
I'm figuring it's got to go up from here
right can only get better so this is
good I mean you can't get more
depressing you have in fact already
begun to die okay
you look great don't get me wrong
and you know you are using Beauty you
are at the physical peak your bodies
have just gotten off the ski slope on
the peak of growth and potential and now
comes the Black Diamond mogul run to the
grave
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because telling it like
it is mm asked me to if there's someone
you like me to profile in the next top
ten check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote
I'd also love to know what was your
favorite message from this video what
did you learn from this video that
you're going to immediately apply
somehow in your life or in your business
please leave it down the comments below
I'm really curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to Oscar
and animal Oscar thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word doing your review on your YouTube
channel and posting it on your Twitter
account as well I really really really
appreciate the support man and I'm so
glad that you enjoyed the block today's
book book report is the one word by Evan
Carmichael so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
your story life-energy here they haven't
written this university has created what
about it has to be artistically
fulfilling or challenging for you for
students because for me what was
surprised that you can shake here what
that is not by my fancy is that move
let's pretend a long time where you had
written and it wasn't exactly yeah you
know really the only things I directed
that and written that all were episodes
of the office and Glee because I love
those shows and I knew the people who
are doing them and I was going to say I
had free time but I'm pretty sure I need
my career is on those kids um but and I
but something like The Avengers to being
cast this whole universe huge history
that I know and and it's it's all you
know you if you can't find your own way
in then you just don't do it the fact
the matter is because I've been a script
doctor to get the showrunner I was used
to coming in with things were already
said after the pilot up show everything
a lot of works been done and you're you
know you're interpreting what you got
there when you come into the script
doctor you know they're like and then it
goes into a plane I'm like I have a way
better idea that we already bought the
plane
I'm kidding we worked Norfolk plains
it's good dinner so you know you just
serve you have to pee now you find the
heart of the thing you find your heart
of the thing with marvel I said look I
know what you want this is what I want I
want make a war movie I want to make the
Dirty Dozen I want to make Black Hawk
Down I don't want to make a squeaky
clean perfect I want to take a toll on
these guys and they're like we get that
we love it do it in the mighty Marvel
Manor and everybody wins
so we knew going in you know that I had
my obsessions that they fit in that
universe with this you know it's a
question of you know interpreting his
work the way I would which is in a
depressing fashion you know it's it's
very easy to fall in love with something
what the entire world is covered with
water include me in and yes you can get
heartbroken but but you have to start
that way and the parameter is they
always exist if you're doing a genre if
you're doing you know it's a comedy
they must laugh already you know the
page is not totally blank so how much of
it is filled in it's completely written
like this whether it's whether there are
a lot of elements are set by the vendors
or whether it's a show that's yours but
it's been on for four years you know you
always have to find a new way in how do
you go from like we're big-budget
Avengers to this 12-day scene in your
home and so there's there's no
difference between the big reveal some
little ones for me you know you're
always fighting everybody's schedule in
this case because they'll had day jobs
in the other case because they're all
famous you're always getting your set
the last minute you're always behind
you're always worried about the same
things they're always trying to
communicate the same things shooting
they're shooting storytelling is
storytelling if you're not writing about
yourself why are you writing for me if
you're not telling the story spinning
the yarn is fine and there are some
people who are great at it and they're
great at things that I'm not great at
like you intricate heist plots and
things that you know that are that I
admire and envy
but if you're if you're sitting down to
write something or make something that's
going to take three years out of your
life why would you not want to tell
people something that's important to you
to say but I don't mean immoral
I just mean an examination of the human
condition you want you want to be able
to talk about the politics of
personality and that's something it took
me a while to find I started to figure
find it on Alien Resurrection which is
the last thing I wrote before Buffy
before the show and that was the first
time I went oh this is a metaphor and
the only way this works is if I feel the
way she feels and that was sort of like
the beginning of becoming a storyteller
instead of a yarn spinner and to me if I
can't do that if I can't make that
connection then I'm wasting people's
time and as men much as I'm a look-back
at anything I made go flawed love love
love love embarrassing embarrassing I
never feel like I did that I never feel
like well I wasted somebody's time
that's the that's the biggest brag I'm
going to give you